hello大家好
歡迎來到周慕姿放心說
我是周慕姿心理師
之前我們有推出一集30歲之前
我希望我知道的事情
那得到蠻多的正向回應
大家都說這一集很不錯
那有一些人就說老師
那有沒有40歲之前
我希望我早點知道的事情
然後我那時候就想一想
40歲之前
我想要早點知道的事情是什麽
我就想了很久
所以呢想了很久之後
我今天決定要來錄這一集
不過這一集跟30歲之前
我希望早點知道的事情
這個風格真的是有點不一樣
因為40歲我們面對更多生活的殘忍啊
被生活的這個鐵拳打的咪咪冒冒
可能有些人獲得了一些資源
但是卻在這個資源當中
有時候會忽略掉一些事情
所以呢我今天這一集
40歲之前
我希望我早點知道的事情呢
想要跟大家分享
我自己的一些人生的體會跟經驗哦
這不一定是正確答案
只是分享我個人的經驗
希望大家就是如果有任何回饋呢
也歡迎留言讓我知道哦
首先第一件事情
這一個第一項呢
其實是我自己的經驗
以及我問了一些身邊的朋友哦
他們給我的回應
40歲之前你會學會一個真諦
那就是人生只能靠自己啊
但是這個只能靠自己的意思是
你可能也需要把你的注意力
開始放回自己身上
原因是因為呢
其實以台灣的一個就是社會結構來說
有蠻多二三十歲的年輕人
有一些機會就是家庭可以提供的資源
或是家庭可以提供的一些協助
比較多
包含我生涯要選什麽啊
包含我家裡可能有點經濟
可以協助我去念書
或者是買房子
或者是
可能我身邊有一些人
他有一些工作資源可以分享給我
等等這一些東西
但是其實到你快要到40歲
30歲到40歲這些時間
你會慢慢發現
你人生會有一些困難
是你身邊的人沒有辦法協助的
那個東西就是屬於你自己的東西
然後另外一個部分
你身邊的資源當然也會越來越少
比如說父母年紀越來越大了
他們可能也有他們自己
就是經濟上
需要提供他們自己退休生活的部分
然後另外一個部分是
你發現就是可能你會的東西
跟你走的路
身邊的人可以提供的一些價值
也越來越少
所以呢在30歲到40歲之間呢
我覺得需要去開始思考的部分就是
我要怎麽增加我自己需要的
生活的一些技能
然後以及呢
我要怎麽樣
讓我自己可以提供我想要的東西
以及我要怎麽應對
有時候我人生遇到的一些困難
我就這一段時間是不停在訓練自己
這個部分
以及呢會開始練習
把你的注意力從別人身上
放回自己身上
比如說你可能比較年輕的時候就會說
你看因為我父母這樣對我
所以我會變成這樣
尤其是我們講到很多童年創傷啊
或者是很多應對策略
都跟你的童年有關
所以有很多人就會說
你看就是因為我爸媽這樣
所以我才會變成這樣
可是到30歲到40歲的時候
我覺得比較重要
當然我覺得二十幾歲就可以做這件事
可是我覺得30歲之後
你會更明顯的意識到
如果你永遠都在想因為別人怎樣
所以我會變成這樣
你會非常的辛苦
因為你會遇到越來越多的情況
就是別人是不會改變的
別人是不會調整的
而你自己一直把注意力跟期待
都放在別人身上
你已經花了十幾年都是這麽想的時候
你到30歲如果還一直繼續這麽想
你的生活就會變得更辛苦
所以開始把注意力放回自己身上
面對別人的評價
別人的要求
別人的一些就是影響
我要怎麽去思考的是
那我要怎麽應對
如果這些人他們不會改變
我要怎麽應對
我是要離他遠一點
還是我要開始調整我跟他互動的方式
還是我要開始
如果他不能給我我想要的東西
我要怎麽給自己想要東西
以及重新思考這個關系
對我來說需不需要
我要開始做選擇
這些東西就會變得越來越重要
所以不管是你在資源上
增加自己的技能也好
或者是你開始讓你的情緒
變得比較平穩
就是你可以讓你自己不要被影響也好
這所有的東西
都是為了讓你生活變得比較平靜
比較有餘裕
然後呢
你也會越來越清楚你自己的標準
你自己想要去的方向
以及你還要借由這個方向
去培養哪一個技能
這一些東西都是非常重要
因為這時候是為了幫助我們去獲得
我們未來
就是40歲之後
越來越想要的自己的生活
不然我們就很容易
會面對到中年危機
或是像現在很很多人在講的
中年之路啊
個體化
其實都是在畫下我們未來的藍圖
去想我們想要的生活是什麽
所以我認為30歲到40歲
有很大一塊是要面對這樣的事情
所以
既然一開始我們要面對這樣的事情
所以第二點就會遇到另外一個
我覺得更重要事情
就是
不要抱怨時間不夠
因為時間只會越來越不夠
那就是很多人會發現哦
到30歲到40歲
人生甚至40幾歲以後
你會感覺到你非常非常忙
有很多人會如果
有一些你自己想要的事情
你有過著你想要的人生
你就會發現我如果有家庭有什麽
我就覺得為什麽我每天都這麽忙
然後每天事情都這麽多
然後你說你做了什麽了不起的大事
也沒有但是你呢
就是被很多瑣碎的事情
把你的時間全部都填滿了
這個就是我覺得年紀越大
越容易會出現的狀況
那就是不只是你有想要做的事情
而是你身邊會有越來越多人
會跟你要求事情
包含你的責任啊
你的健康啊
家人有些事情你要幫忙啊
或者是工作上有很多很多要求啊
等等的
所以我認為30歲到40歲這段時間
還有一個很重要的選擇
就是我要篩選
篩選什麽
篩選我想要花時間在什麽事情上
因為有時候我覺得我是學習
可是如果今天我的學習其實是
包含我其實是很焦慮的
我其實是很擔心我比不上別人的
就是我們前面講
我的注意力還在別人的標準上
社會主流的價值上
我可能還沒有機會花很多時間
去理解我自己真正想要的
包含我想要過的生活是什麽
我想要的標準是什麽
我想要的目標是什麽
還沒有時間去想這件事情
我就會很容易把我的時間花在
好像我做了很多事
但是其實那些事情
不一定是我未來想要的生活裡面
很需要去累積的事情
這也就是為什麽我們現在常會講說
有很多人有錯失恐懼症哦
有所謂的FOMO
FOBO阿
選擇障礙等等
因此我覺得30歲到40歲這一段時間
去選擇自己想要的東西
還敢跟別人說我不要什麽東西
或是跟自己說我不要什麽東西
即使那個東西是主流
大家都說很棒的東西等等
我覺得這件事情是很重要的訓練
而這就回歸到我們剛剛前面講的
你越能夠跟你自己相處
你越能夠把注意力放在自己身上
你才知道什麽東西你真的要或不要
在做不要的選擇的時候
你才能夠比較堅定
不會害怕
那麽你就可以把你的時間跟力氣
留給你想要的東西
再來第三點
我們就會開始進入實際上的部分
第一個就是存錢
存錢這件事情
我不知道大家的狀況怎麽樣
其實我在30歲之前
我是不太會存錢的
我在30歲之前的薪水
其實就是一般的上班族
反而是在那個時候
我花錢是還蠻大手大腳的
就基本來說就是月光
我真的是沒有什麽存錢的習慣
那我之前有在一些Podcast分享過
我在30歲的時候
家裡出現很大的經濟危機
所以在那個時候我第一次發現哎
如果今天我要靠我自己生活
我如果今天因為某些原因失去了收入
我大概可以撐多久
那時候讓我第一次意識到
存錢這件事情真的好重要
而且包含現在很多人會講
什麽要理財啊
什麽買股票啊
什麽買基金啊什麽的
老實說你沒有存錢
你所有的東西都沒有
先有一筆就是很實在
叫做第一桶金
你沒有先有一個
就是Base的話
你要去做什麽投資
其實壓力都會很大
所以存錢這件事情
基本來說就是重新的去思考
你跟錢的關系
那在這個過程中
我必須要思考很實際的問題
就是沒有收入
我可以撐幾個月
那我花的錢是需要還是補償
如果我今天倒下了
我沒有辦法賺錢了
會受到什麽樣影響
我身邊的人會不會被影響
我會不會自己也被影響
存錢這件事情
跟前面我講的存時間
你把時間花在自己身上
開始拒絕
其實是一樣的
存錢
就是幫我開始拒絕我不需要的消費
這些事情都是為了什麽
不管是金錢也好
或是時間也好
都是為了幫我存下我以後的餘裕
也就是我未來生活想要做什麽的時候
我想要有餘裕的時候
我想要就是可以有一些選擇的時候
我覺得這些
事情都是為了讓我們存下這個部分
所以我的確也是從三十幾歲
重新開始做心理師的工作
我才開始存錢
然後再加上因為我們心理師的工作
如果你不是一般的專任
你是像我一樣
就是就是行動心理師
就是可能跟很多單位合作
然後在哪裡拿一筆錢
在哪裡拿一筆錢
那個時候存錢就變得非常重要
因為不然你很容易拿錢
拿到之後就把它花掉
所以我那時候就是鼓勵自己
去買一些零存整付
就是平常隨時都可以存錢進去
然後可存了之後就拿不出來
然後他可能會到一個時間點
比如一年或多少年
他就會把錢給你
加上利息
然後呢就會是一筆錢你就可以拿去
也許你要做投資
或是你要做什麽事情都可以
這個部分
我那時候就開始開這樣的戶頭
做這樣的存款
所以我蠻鼓勵
如果你現在才30出頭
然後你本身沒有存錢習慣的人
我非常鼓勵你
就是一定要有存錢的習慣
如果可以的話
讓自己有3-6個月沒有薪水
可以過生活的一個基本金
就是一個你最開始存錢的第一個目標
那接下來第四點就是理財
理財能力這件事情哦
我覺得也是一個我在30歲之前
我從來沒想過的事
因為我以前從來不相信理財
原因是因為在我這個年紀哦
我們是經過金融海嘯
還有那個什麽台股大跌
跌到4,000點的那種過程
所以我們曾經看過身邊的大人就是
投入股市之後賠光光
或是很慘
很可憐
所以我們對股市的思考就是賠錢
就是騙錢
然後就是不是投資
是投機
至少我的印象
因為我那個年代的印象是這樣
你就可以想像一下
就跟現在日本人一樣
為什麽很多日本人
就是他們現在三四十歲
四十幾歲他們不買房子
原因就是因為他們經歷過泡沫經濟
就是買房子之後
很多人後來付不出來
然後甚至做出一些很決絕的事情
所以他們對於買房子這件事情
印象非常差
因此我們那時候對理財觀念是這樣
可是到三四十歲之後
我才發現理財這件事情非常非常重要
不亞於存錢
可是那時候我已經大概40出頭
快40歲才開始思考理財這件事情
然後好像40歲才開始做這件事
那個時候我就覺得哎
如果我早一點開始做這件事情就好了
也不會多花那麽多錢
就是因為你以前年輕的時候
就是有多的錢
你不知道幹嘛
你也不理財
你就很容易花掉
可是當你可以理財的時候
你就等於是你拿去買衣服的錢
變成買別的東西
可能買基金啊
買股票也是買東西哦
但是那個錢他是會幫你賺錢的
所以會有一些差別
可是我覺得理財
可能有些人就說哦
老師所以你現在要推薦名牌
絕對不是
我現在跟大家討論的是理財這件事情
他必須要思考幾個部分
一個是你對金錢的態度是什麽
你為什麽花錢
為什麽存錢
你是屬於喜歡把錢
留在身上
還是你一有錢就會覺得趕快把它花掉
如果你是一有錢
就要趕快把它花掉的人
是因為你要拿來換安全感
還是你省錢到一個狀態
是你用來控制你的焦慮
所以我們在理財的這個部分
其實是重新思考
你個人的金錢腳本是什麽
你在面對錢你的態度是什麽
因此我們在做理財這件事情
其實有很大的一個部分是
他等於是讓你除了就是自己日常生活
主要的賺錢的部分之外
你有你的金錢有機會在幫你賺錢
而讓你有一個余裕
怎麽去安排這個部分
就會變成是很重要的事情
所以說在這一種情況之下
可能就會有一些人
在面對理財這件事情
都覺得是投機哦
當然我覺得
每個人就是選擇的理財方式不一樣
不過我個人真的比較建議大家
把理財這個東西的思考
比較接近像存錢一樣的方式
你在在想理財這件事情
不是突然致富
不是突然賺大錢
而是幫助你有一點一點的累積
而能夠未來有更多的選擇跟余裕
所以這是我比較建議
在思考理財的時候
你可以思考的方式
所以如果你的理財方式
是希望一開始做就要賺大錢
就要變成很大的一個資金進來
不然理財這個東西好像沒有效果
我覺得這件事情
反而就會讓你重新去思考
為什麽我只要一投入一件事情
我只要沒有辦法馬上看到結果
我就不太想做
所以這其實也是幫助我們重新思考
我們的人生觀的一個部分
另外規劃退休
三四十歲就要規劃退休
哎我跟你們講真的耶
你你覺得四五十歲你再想退休哦
原因是因為三四十歲
其實算是我們人生不管是體力也好
很多事情頭腦的狀態也也好的一個
算是比較接近巔峰啊
有些人說二十幾歲是巔峰
因為二十幾歲是創意
可是我反而覺得
二十幾歲因為經驗還不足
對自己的理解還沒有那麽高
然後對於社會的理解
也還不一定那麽高
可是我真的覺得
30歲開始就開始是一個巔峰
所以在你巔峰的時候去規劃退休
反而是會讓你比較知道
你現在擁有的東西很棒
但是也許你以後可以擁有更多
那如果你現在這個東西很棒
你可以把這個很棒的東西放在哪里
因此這個規劃退休不是說哦
我我現在30歲
要去想我要存到多少錢才可以退休
當然這是一個一個想法
可是我覺得更重要的是
我以後想過怎麽樣的生活
我長期想過什麽樣的生活
我40歲想在哪里
我50歲想在哪里
我60歲想在哪里
我想跟誰在一起
我想要自己一個人
還是我想要過怎麽樣的生活
然後那個樣貌是什麽
你越有清楚的畫面
你對於你自己的理財工作生涯
還有你的生活
就比較會有一個目標跟方向
因此我覺得規劃退休這件事情
可以說是你的生活規劃
你越清楚你想要怎麽活
你越有現實感
這時候你要去計算
你多少錢才足夠退休
就會越清楚
所以簡單的說規劃退休這件事情
就是鼓勵30歲到40歲的你
可以多一點現實感
而不是只是被生活帶著跑
你可以更容易的就是停下來
讓自己把力氣可以投注在
自己想要的事情上
我覺得這件事情是很重要
然後接下來我就是一樣
就是我說後面都是很有現實感的東西
那就是健康檢查跟重訓
我們上一次30歲我有講到運動
可是我覺得是30歲到40歲
我想要更鼓勵大家
要記得固定的健康檢查
原因是因為三十幾歲的你
你會覺得你不需要健康檢查
你大部分三十幾歲你不會想健康檢查
會有想固定健康檢查
很多人都是35歲之後已經算不錯
有很多人是40歲之後
可是其實我們的體力
跟我們身體的狀況
尤其是在現在忙碌的社會
比我們想象中的耗損更大
所以有固定的健康檢查
只是讓我們更清楚
我們身體有什麽地方需要留意
你的身體哪個地方你本來覺得還好
可是你去做健康檢查之後
他可能會提醒你說這個狀況還好
但是他可能有點小紅字哦
你可能要注意哦
所以
這是幫助我們去用很物理性的方式
去了解你的身體
還有培養跟你和身體的關係
然後懂得照顧身體
重訓的部分我我不是講有氧運動
我講重訓
是因為我們就是的確到一個年紀之後
肌肉就是會開始減少
最近才在跟我朋友聊天
我印象中我那時候真的是35、36歲之後
可以感覺到我的體力跟身體狀況
立刻雪崩式下跌
那個雪崩式下跌真的是很明顯
所以重訓這件事情是增加你的肌肉量
我很喜歡那時候
在做重訓的時候
我一個朋友他跟我講
他鼓勵我去做重訓
然後他跟我講了一句話
我很喜歡
他說我希望我到七十幾歲的時候
我不用靠著輪椅去很多地方
我可以靠著我自己的腿去任何地方
我覺得有這個畫面
就會讓你覺得現在在做這些努力
是為了讓我們自己
可以過著我們以後更想要的生活
所以我覺得這訓
讓我們可以就是包含心理
在承受很多事情
或是肌肉上的訓練
都會讓我們生活中
有時候在一些困難的時候
比較能夠承受
而健康檢查
其實會讓我們可以更去留意
我們身體的一些狀況
然後知道怎麽去照顧
然後去維護
所以你可以想象到三四十歲之後
你的身體
已經都是用了快要一半的時間
所以好好的去照顧你的身體
我覺得這件事情是很重要的
那接下來就是一個
我覺得也是一個很現實的
就是保險跟長照
三十幾歲的你
可能不太會覺得
保險這件事情有那麽重要
到四十幾歲你就會開始覺得很重要
所以我真的很鼓勵大家
三十幾歲就可以開始研究這件事
那關於長照
也就是長期照護這個部分哦
我們三十幾歲會面對到父母
大概就是五六十或六十幾歲
這個時候的父母
都還沒有那麽需要這件事情
可是你越早開始規劃這件事情
你會發現到了
父母那個年紀的時候
你比較會有余裕
我們現在做的所有事情
都是為了讓我們
跟讓我們未來的生活有余裕
所以關於長照關於保險
你可以怎麽去思考你自己的需要等等
這也是基於你的健康檢查
去讓你可以更清楚
你未來需要的東西是什麽
或是你身邊的人需要的是什麽
讓你的生活比較有餘裕
有幫助的一個思考
不過我的確有聽說目前台灣的長照險
他能夠保有的東西
其實比我們想象中的少
所以請大家務必要好好理解跟研究
這件事情很重要
最後哦後面3點就是比較是
我們心理層面的東西
所以我會鼓勵大家也可以開始去思考
我認為30歲到40歲很重要的事情
就是自我覺察跟情緒調節
自我覺察跟情緒調節
其實是我在很多地方都不停重覆
包含我在停止內耗這門課
也一直希望大家
可以努力去建立的東西
原因是因為我們30歲到40歲
會覺得壓力很大
你放心 40歲之後你壓力會更大
所以你越在30歲到40歲
如果你發現
你跟情緒的關係沒有那麽好
你也發現你現在對情緒很多東西
你是忍耐
40歲之後你就會發現你沒辦法忍耐
你脾氣就會越來越差
越來越容易不耐煩
然後看你如果有伴侶
看另一半你也會越來越不爽等等
這些東西都是很正常
所以如果你可以從三十幾歲開始
就能夠開始了解自己
穩定自己的情緒
了解自己情緒狀況不好的時候
可以怎麽照顧自己
這件事情
對我們就會很重要
所以你到四十幾歲的時候
就會成為你想要的情緒穩定的大人
好為什麽要從三十幾歲開始做
你相信我
做這件事情不是一兩年就做得到的
我真的是從開始學諮商之後
開始學這件事
到現在
我覺得我勉強有些時候可以情緒穩定
但有些時候我還是覺得我好急躁哦
這個部分真的是沒有辦法那麽好
請大家相信一件事
我們前額葉哦
也就是控制衝動
讓我們情緒變得穩定的那個部分
會越來越退化
二十幾歲前額葉開始成熟
四十幾歲開始退化
所以基本上使用的時間真的很短吶
所以
你要怎麽樣讓它可以使用時間比較長
就是在
你越能夠訓練你自己的自我覺察
跟情緒調節的能力
你越長使用你的前額葉
讓你前額葉對你的情緒越來越理解
然後越來越可以加入
在很多時候
你不是每次都是用直覺去做事情
你會先停一下
讓你的情緒可以
你的大腦可以想一下
說好那接下來我要怎麽做
就是這樣
你訓練前額葉
就這麽簡單
就讓他想一下接下來我要怎麽做
你越會訓練他
他就越不容易退化
你的情緒就會越穩定
這件事情要花很長很長的時間
我覺得我花了十幾年
還不是讓我自己很滿意哦
可是我的確覺得
我現在情緒穩定度比以前高
這對我來說的幫助很大
因此也讓我在面對比較大的
工作壓力的時候
能夠有比較穩定的情緒
所以跟大家分享
第九點我想跟大家分享的是
三四十歲之後
因為你會越來越忙
所以你可能身邊有連接的人越來越少
可是我要鼓勵大家
盡可能的去建立正向連接的
正向連接不是說去增加人脈
讓你的工作變得更好
有些人可能會覺得這件事情很重要
我比較強調的是是你需要增加
讓你覺得相處上可以誠實相處
而且會是比較不那麽用力
可以比較自在的人
因為當你有辦法
越了解你自己
你就越敢選擇讓你比較不辛苦的人
你可以充電的關係
你越來越可以不勉強自己
我覺得這件事情是很重要
就是你可以想象你的體力慢慢在退化
你的時間越來越少
所以在這一些有限的時間
你能夠越來越不勉強自己
對你是最棒的
所以這是我很鼓勵大家可以做的事情
因此最後一點就是我最後的提醒
所有所有前面講的那9點
就是一個原則
那就是我們是為了讓自己有選擇
而且你有選擇跟有餘裕之後
你會願意給別人
我自己有很深的感受
我30歲到40歲那一段時間
其實非常非常的努力
特別是我三十幾歲出來工作之後
我那時候真的是拿命在拼工作
非常非常可怕的工作量
我現在想起來都覺得好恐怖
可是我發現我那個時候的努力
對我現在的幫助是什麽
那就是
當我那麽努力去做很多事情的時候
就是為了讓
現在的我
在很多事情上變得比較有選擇
有餘裕然後可以越來越不勉強
但是
我的確是三十幾歲才開始做這件事
所以當我之前跟大家分享30歲前
你可以知道的是
你可以給自己一些努力
一些支持
然後你盡可能不要逃避
很不容易的事情
那麽接下來在你後面的人生中
你就越有機會可以過你想要的人生
做更多的選擇
所謂有選擇的人生
不是說你就是永遠都是正確選擇
永遠都是最好的選擇
不是
有選擇的人生
就是說你在困難的時候有不同的可能
也就是在有些時候你可以選擇不妥協
有些時候你可以選擇離開
有些時候你可以選擇重新開始
你不用因為現實而被逼著留下
我們一定會有一些時間點
是必須被現實逼著留下
逼著沒有選擇
可是只要你能夠在那個時候
你好好的把這個決定做好
努力的往你自己想要的方向去努力
去累積的時候
你的未來就會越來越有選擇
越來越會有自由
我覺得這就是我們人生的目的
不是做最好的
而是讓自己有空間
如果當有一天
你可以成為一個有選擇的人
我覺得能夠在那個時候也給別人空間
給別人機會那個部分
我覺得是一件很棒的事情
原因是因為當你有了選擇
有了空間
你願意給別人
那會呈現一個正向循環
別人也會給你
你的空間跟選擇又會變得更多
你和別人的正向連接也會更好
這個心里慷慨
其實是會讓我們之間變得很正向
最近我看到很多在講
就是小孩在吵啊
父母都不好好照顧啊這種過程哦
我在看的時候
其實也覺得
有時候也可以理解
這兩邊的人到底發生什麽事
因為我覺得
當我們今天
沒有辦法給自己很多的余裕的時候
我們對於身邊的失控跟不可控的東西
或是覺得被侵犯界限的東西
我們幾乎完全無法忍耐
我記得我最近因為常常搭飛機
所以有一次在飛機上
我前面有一個小孩
因為飛機起飛很不舒服
所以就開始哭哦
本來前面都很乖
然後後來就開始狂哭
哭很久大概哭了三四十分鐘
然後那時候我們正在吃東西
在我們附近隔壁有個位置
的一個人
他就一直很在意
一直跟他們父母講說
可以處理一下嗎
真的很吵什麽的
然後你就感覺父母非常的焦慮
然後一直在罵小孩
一直在念小孩
然後小孩就哭的更慘
然後我自己覺得
這件事情很有趣的地方是
我誠實的說
在我三十幾歲的時候
或是再更年輕一點
我對這個狀況也會很不耐煩
可是現在的我
對這個狀況不但不會不耐煩
我反而會覺得這是一個可理解的狀態
第一個原因我想應該是因為
當然是我學這一行
我越來越能理解小孩的狀況
他就是用這個方式在表達他不舒服
而父母有時候能做的東西
沒有我們想象中的多
可是另外一個
我覺得更大的部分是
我沒有已經覺得
我的生活一定要全部都很舒服
我覺得對我來說
因為我自己能夠給我自己很舒服
跟在這個狀態上
能夠調節自己情緒的一個好的感覺
所以我在面對
當旁邊有一些刺激的時候
我也比較不容易被影響
所以我就比較能夠給自己舒服
這也就是我想跟大家講的
當你越能夠照顧你自己
你越能調節你的情緒
你的情緒跟感受
越不會被外在刺激給影響
因為對於那個人來說
有些人可能會說哦
他好不寬容什麽
但是說實話
我覺得他也很辛苦
因為他很容易被別人的刺激給影響
他被影響之後
他就整個人被影響
他完全沒有辦法忽略掉
那個小孩的聲音
所以
如果今天假設他有機會可以自我照顧
能夠不那麽容易被那個刺激影響
他是不是就不會因為對方的狀況
而改變自己的行為
或改變自己心里的狀況
所以我覺得
當我們越能夠照顧自己
我們狀況越好
我們越有選擇
我們也有機會越給別人選擇跟空間
我覺得這個東西真的是互相的
所以我倒不是想要去講說哪一邊是好
或哪一邊是壞
我只想跟大家講
當這個狀況的時候
我們越能理解
我們就越能夠幫助自己
甚至我們也有餘裕去幫助別人
而不會覺得自己好像是在犧牲
或是很痛苦
這是我想跟大家分享的東西
所以40歲之前
我想跟大家分享的
不只是我們可以撐起自己的東西
我想如果今天有機會
我們也可以扶別人一把
是多的然後
我覺得這個世界可能也會變得更美好
因此跟大家分享
40歲之前
我希望自己知道的事
好的
那麽今天周慕姿放心說
我們下次見嘍
掰掰